just to uh course off to the urban asked
a great question right what this does is
a focusing on a particular kind of
question it eliminates the experiment
pretty rules it uses addition instead of
subtraction those are all advantages but
what it focuses on is these guys devices
like X minus three or devices like X
plus two okay we have fancy names for
this right number one they're Manik
because that leading coefficient is one
but number two do you remember I told
you it when it's got degree to become
quadratic degree three is called cubic
degree four is called quartic this is
degree 1 what's that call if you graph
this it's a straight line it's a linear
right so focus is on my neck linear
divisors okay now here's the thing
though we're where this some skill goes
to and you end up using it in curves
sketchy you end up using it in um excuse
me
a big topic or calculus next to you when
you're differentiate and integrate stuff
you don't even know what that is yeah
but the important thing is for all of
those processes where you're going right
what you're going to do need abiding by
like 99% of the time if not more it's
something that's Manik and then you're
right this is the use case that comes up
again and again and again it's just kind
of a curiosity that you don't have to
make it money continue I can do long
division for anything I live but those
are the things like if I divided it
instead of dividing by that okay if I
wanted to I could define like this if
you want to go to your life um but that
tends to be like not a very useful
process like that doesn't end up being
very practical doesn't end up being a
very useful thing to do in a large
number of situations whereas this time
this kind of problem it comes up again
again so even though this method focuses
on that kind of problem I have no
problem with that because that's the
most important one about them okay so
what I'm gonna ask you to do is um
because this looks so different
it looks so different I want you to
practice this right now you've got
plenty of thing I want you to take take
any of the questions in power any other
questions on what I mean we did we did
name soon so go to H okay but pick any
of the other ones and in fact people um
I think I okay is a great one because
that takes you like 10 minutes just to
write the thing out okay and do it with
synthetic I'll give you two minutes to
do that and then I'll show you my answer
on the board it's really quick okay do I
like I said once you get in the in the
rhythm it just it's it's so fast it's so
fast and even just this if this is the
only difference this would save your
dramatic weather time okay let's have a
go I've already set up my coefficients
and there's my divisor the technical way
of saying it by the way is this is the
zero of the divisor it's the thing that
if I put this in to X it would make the
whole thing zero what I'm doing this
thing well I just write down the first
number there we go and here comes my
repeating step right I'm multiplying and
then I add I multiply and then I add I
multiply and then I add I multiply and
then I add I multiply and then I add
yeah
is it look okay give me some notes yeah
the division is done okay now all I need
to do is just translate it back into
this this represents a polynomial with a
remainder of the end okay now
remembering that I was dividing by
something weird on this was degree five
this thing up here and this thing was
degree one so therefore my question
should be degree four in fact it always
just goes down one okay I miss cases so
this guy is going to be an X to the
before so I've got a single X - 4 I've
got this many X cubes I've got this many
X Squared's this many X's that's just a
constant
and then this guy named Akhil he's my
arm a dog so quick so efficient when you
when I first like this it like feels
like you got a superpower
oh it just it's done okay so I find it
much quicker like I said if you see this
which is the boss majority of times just
go for it pull out okay if in that small
number of cases you get something like
this okay you do need to do long
division I would just quickly show you
our wave leadership but I'll started for
you I said you could do this I say you
can do that you haven't really seen
frequently I'm having to divide by
something with more terms in it like we
usually see a pair of terms but it works
in just the same way it's just the bits
law so for example if I did I'll do it
long yeah okay
um here is my here's the divisor that I
chose because I'm gonna put myself
through some pain okay here's my
dividend 3x squared minus X once I read
a violent yep okay now if I had to do
this long way if I had no choice okay ah
again I think that the most important
term the most important term which is
just the leading term right how many X
squares fit into X cubed - 2 X because
remember I've got to multiply this back
to get the same thing so when I multiply
back I get 2x cubed plus 4x squared
minus 2x now this looks cursed but it's
just a bit longer that's all it is
so when I do the subtraction this goes
to 0 this here goes to 3x squared
takeaway 4x squared is minus x squared
minus X take away minus 2x becomes plus
2x so that's gonna be plus X right and
then this minus will come a little for
the ride okay I lost the question again
how many X Squared's here 2 minus x
squared monster and it's just minus 1
right and I multiply back and I get
minus x squared minus 2x plus 1 okay
those two cancel here I get
three X take away five yeah okay now
something is interesting here and it's
not the most important thing but it's
still worth pointing out 3x minus 5 I've
got nothing left to bring down right
there's nothing left to right
how many times is x squared going to 3x
minus 5 and the answer is it doesn't go
ahead like the x squared term is already
bigger than what's here so I've been it
that's my remainder it's weird that the
remainder has an X in it but that's
because what we were dividing by was an
x squared